you're going on tour is that correct
yeah i'm doing i'm doing all like the
flyover states because people come out
to my shows they say you know i drove
four hours i drove six hours
so i want to go like to where they're at
and uh
it's like boise deadwood south dakota
for some reason there's a lot of meth
they have those creepy before and after
i gotta hand it to this generation like
i didn't think any they were gonna outdo
us
where when i saw crack babies i was like
that's it like that's as far as you can
go
as far as the creepy thing not condoning
it i'm just saying it was creepy
and they came up those meth people they
literally looked like they could just
go on the walking dead it's unbelievable
so
i i got it not condoning it just giving
them kudos
so agreeing with the crowd cracking
babies were scary to look at
so you you you have you ever would you
be able to live in one of these cities
do you think you're going to tour you're
going to go you're going to do your act
but do you think you could
live in one of these cities that's my
game plan my game plan
so i'm gonna try to buy something out
here out here now
probably all the houses out here look
like little cheesecake factories to me
so i'm gonna buy one of those and then
when this business is done with me
i'm just gonna sell it and i'll go i'm
just going to retire someplace
no one wants to live middle of alabama
and get a house like 40 bucks
you got a giant house 45 yeah it's like
40 bucks and then you just have to
understand
that there's gonna be you have to have
like an acceptable level you're gonna
have to tolerate
like meth and like racism like
like on either side like you know paula
deen paula dean might be like next door
having some weird party some slavery
themed thing
picking up some buttery methods